well I mean we thought we've gone
through a huge evolution of what is
going on with beer in New York City I
mean new york new york city started
brewing pretty much as soon as people
showed up brewery started here the
heyday of brewing in New York City would
have been the late 1800s to around 1900
you had more than 100 breweries in
Manhattan you had 48 in Brooklyn and
Brooklyn actually came first because we
have a different water supply than
Manhattan does you know we are on
Catskill delaware water whereas most of
been Hatton is on croton-harmon water at
one time where the new york city public
library main branches at forty-second
street that is where in bryan park
that's where the reservoir was so the
reservoir was this big walled thing and
the water was horrible it was disgusting
and so you couldn't make decent beer out
of it so people would move out to
Brooklyn to build the breweries so at
the turn of the century you know in 1900
one out of every ten beers produced in
the United States was made in Brooklyn
it was one of the great brewing capitals
of the world and at that time you know
the breweries were a big part of
everyone's social life because they were
huge you know beer gardens that that
helped thousands and thousands of people
and of course after prohibition wiped
out brewing in the United States and at
that time we had thousands of breweries
the United States by 1974 we only had 40
breweries left and they all made one
kind of beer which was essentially
flavorless and I think of brewing as
being very much like our food culture
which has had a big comeback you know in
the last 20 years but at the time that
you know I first moved to England there
was really only one kind of beer and
what it really was was a beer facsimile
the same way that when you go to the
soup America and you see that big spongy
loaf of white bread you know it's really
a chemical sponge it's not bread bread
doesn't have 40 ingredients and stay
fresh in a bag for two weeks you know so
we're actually going back to what beer
had been before New York City has
actually been relatively slow to catch
up with the west coast which started the
connoisseurship of beer which and that
grew out of their connoisseurship 414
wine starting in the late 70s and early
80's and then kind of leap frogged
across the rest of the country to New
York City we kind of got going you know
in the 80s though an early pioneer male
and that takes me to my early days was
Manhattan Brewing Company open in 1984
and they were the first new brew pub
east of the Mississippi since
Prohibition so that was an outpost but
we finally have kind of caught up with
the rest of the country and in some way
surpassed it you know if you go to
Gramercy Tavern you now see that they
have a vintage beer list beyond their
huge you know beer list period and of
course Gramercy you know is among the
top restaurants in New York City and
therefore the world so it's a you know
we've come a long way and there are many
great you know bars and restaurants here
but what we're really hoping for what
we're seeing is is beer good beer
becoming part of the everyday culture in
all bars not spatulas bars and
restaurants
well I get myself in a lot of trouble
with a question like that but certainly
I wouldn't miss the blind tiger which is
the premier beer bar in New York City
down in the West Village I would
recommend going to Gramercy Tavern
forgetting the sort of fine dining with
great beer experience and you know there
are two parts the restaurant you you
know you the tavern room up front is
less expensive than you know the you
know the other part of the restaurant
and they don't take reservations so you
can actually get in normally Gramercy
Tavern has just sold out for you know at
least a month and really come and
experience that so from either end you
know the beer bar and I'd say that blind
tiger is the top of the list you can
also check out the spotted pig in the
west village now become rather famous so
maybe going on an afternoon sometime and
you know they actually have some of the
British style beer on the hand pump the
cask ale to serve with April Bloomfield
tremendous food so place with a Michelin
star you know and you know end cask
conditioned beer you know that's a
wonderful combination